leur régime vous avez vidéo vous avez eu
des bas on va vous faire une interview à
peine d'annoncer normal
[Applaudissements]
régine ce que vous préférez en vous la
couleur de mes cheveux
bien gines ce que vous haïssez en vous 1
quand tu prends du poids jean ce que
vous préférez dans la nuit le petit
matin ce que vous détestez dans la nuit
j'ai d'un v6 qui viennent le plus grand
moment de votre vie
les plus beaux moments de ma vie c'est
la naissance de ma petite fille
le pire moment
le pire moment c'est
quand effectivement claude a été arrêté
votre plus gros coup de fric
c'était très longue pendant 25 ans non
votre plus grosse perte
pendant ces 25 ans aussi j'ai tout jeté
par les fenêtres mais la jugent très
généreuse vous savez quand vous précisez
que vous faisiez des repas chez vous au
dessus du new jimmy'z vous leur faisait
des boulette polonaise s'écouter pas
très cher ça que maintenant ça non mais
quand je faisais aussi caviar violon et
aj auxerre quand je payer des agios avez
vous de crédit bourges était souvent
dans le rouge et quand j'étais très ami
avec beaucoup de banquiers je pensais
qu'ils aient pas à jouer votre heure je
sais pas ce que ça a fait jaser même pas
comment ça s'écrit avec l'accord j'ai
vite appris votre plus belle histoire
d'amour régime
c'est toujours la première claude
vous a marqué
celui qui vous a dépucelé
magnéto serge
la risée des traits
étaient très dans la grande que je
rejoins à peu près l'âge où on se fait
dépuceler maintenant voilà
treize ans et demi ça s'est bien passé
c'était plutôt désagréable sur les bois
non mais c'est vrai et d
expliquer
bien sûr bien sûr
[Musique]
bien alors votre plus minables histoire
d'amour régime à écouter franchement
j'ai pas eu d'histoires d'amour du nabab
non maintenant j'ai eu des grands
histoire avec des gens alors oui
formidable origine vous avez été avec el
cordobès végéter fiancée capteur de
baisse pendant deux ans à la fin petit
matin dans les oreilles et la queue
comme le nom
on était toujours en train de faire la
bourse allé très très bien voilà
régine ce que vous avez de plus sexy en
vous
la voix de moins sexy
mon caractère régine ce que vous
préférez dans le sexe
après quand on rit et on rit après
bah si vous riez pas c'est le baiser mal
des gouttes dans le cinq ce régime a par
le gong iations
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu de
bleu